c'est un passage incontournable avant le
rendez vous aux urnes
l'inscription sur les listes électorales
une obligation depuis 1951
l'abstentionnisme semble être en voie de
disparition
l'abstention peut être pas encore
balayées mais en tout cas fin des années
50 93 % des français en âge de voter
sont inscrits sur les listes électorales
21 ans c'était l'âge minimum pour
s'inscrire sur les listes électorales
jusqu'en 1978 année où il a été abaissé
à 18 ans de responsabilités les jeunes
pour qu'ils soient davantage enregistrés
sur les listes en 1997 nouvelle loi ils
sont automatiquement inscrits sur les
listes à leur majorité
enfin au début il y a eu quelques couacs
gersony convocation ni kardec lectorat
donc je pense qu'un jour j'allais le
système s'est perfectionnée inscription
automatique donc mais à vrai dire depuis
les français ont pris l'habitude de se
déclarer
le taux d'inscription se maintient à un
très haut niveau autour des 90 % l'année
avec le taux le plus faible selon le
ministère de l'intérieur ces 2011 avec
87,3 pour sort tout de même je m'inscris
je pense ça mais c'est juste était
jusqu'au 31 décembre
mais attention fort taux d'inscription
ne dit pas moins d'abstention surtout à
la veille des européennes en 2009 alors
que 88 % des français en âge de voter
sont recensés sur les listes seules 40,5
% des inscrits se sont déplacés aux
urnes
[Musique]